so
[Music]
hi everyone what's up
i was just posting the thing on on
social medias
uh letting you guys look at that
beautiful author i made i thought that i
would intentionally make the art look
bad because it suits the video game
um so to everyone who has not uh
yet seen the first part of
deadly premonition 2 that i streamed
yesterday before
uh embargo was up game comes out today
it's a nintendo switch exclusive that is
this is not at all sponsored in any way
i'm just
getting ahead of people who are gonna
ask we're basically like
in the underground of a warehouse
because um this girl died
oh my god there's so much more to it
than that this is the francis york
morgan
okay he's a he's an fbi agent and he's
come to this town called le carre for
holiday
and this girl died her body was in this
warehouse that her parents owned because
the town is too small and doesn't have a
mork
she was stolen at some point so we're
like investigating the morgue
but that's not actually why we're doing
any of this um we're actually doing this
because a painting in the hotel that
we're staying at
uh spoke to us and said find the ten
maidens
and something to do with the i was
it was something to do with zero
it was like the obscure zero or
something
um which that's not a joke
that this is all this all happened um
and york decided that that would
probably be this place because
the temperatures get low enough to be
zero in fahrenheit or celsius
um so that's where we're at i think i've
caught you on today now
in this ridiculous video game um
i stopped right here because there is a
boss fight at some point and that was in
baghdad yesterday
not a problem now but uh
i have to shoot stuff off the ceiling
right now to get
this guy to notice me so we're gonna do
that oh
oh look like the game for us it was just
a cutscene gets me every time
all right hey boss
okay very awkward interaction but i'm
it's what i'm here for i guess
yes welcome the graphics absolutely look
worse than the fastest
you're absolutely right
hi avery i'm special agent francis york
morgan
please call me york york
i well is he ten foot tall no for the
record
the murderer is uh supposedly like ten
foot tall
um the
victim described him as the size of an
oak come on
just settle down avery everything's
pretty cool
this is melvin we love melvin
melvin is the best expensive food here
your mighty people don't know anything
about everything
to the clarkson's so i gotta guard it
the clarksons are the people who own so
you're this area warehouse also we're in
the south
i help with the research too
i do like research
what are you talking about avery this
doesn't look like a lab to me
oh ain't no lamb
it's a warehouse i don't like him i
don't trust him
he may also be the mother smarty pant
scientist
does the research i ain't no
pants you know i mean if i've ever met
anyone who gave off murder vibes
it's this guy but he ain't a bad guy
we'll find out your story about the
giant who carried
out lisa's dead guy think it's him
i mean it's true that he's free to come
and go as he pleases in this warehouse
but no as far as i can tell he's just a
bit over 6'5
the one who moved lisa's body literally
10 feet tall
he's clearly too short nobody finds this
strange though well i guess the first
game has like supernatural elements
though
ooh who will i think my sister is
watching a man who makes him look small
that's true hi sarah
no this is patricia hey cut it out
she kind of sucks lise
why avery that's not lease
not least wasn't least like a teenager i
don't actually know his daughter
and my precious assistant unfortunately
elise
is no longer with us
please
[Music]
this is the thing they scripted this is
a character that they decided to make
i guess he's sort of like lise why not i
guess
the poor phyllis guys i need to change
something on my monitor
you know how normal kids tease other
kids in order to get attention
well with this big look
sometimes folks who don't know him too
well see something and
end up calling the police but i know
that deep down
he's got a good heart hey mr york
i'll keep em busy but i'd appreciate it
if you'd heard this particular
inspection along
just holler at me if you find anything i
reckon that'll make it easier for you to
go do your thing
yeah okay melvin i think you're finally
starting to catch up this is not a bus
fight good to know
all right we did it we got avery's
attention why did i need to do that oh
that's right
okay the flying serpent right this all
makes perfect sense i don't know why
you're looking at me like you're
confused
um i have to find the flying serpent in
the place of
zero or whatever um because that's what
it told me to do
is the suspect a unit or a chunk
uh it's a good question there are torn
off claws and legs scattered all over
the ground [ __ ] every
you weird dude i doubt they'll i can't
tell which ones are from crawfish how
about you zack
okay yep still looking for the flying
serpent has anyone seen a flying
serpent the painting told me
that is what i needed is this a flying
serpent it's i mean alligators okay it's
hung alligators got it
i suppose in a way they sort of look
like thank you
that's what i was thinking no but that's
pushing it okay
remember we're in a dark basement here
they'll never reach the sky
i don't feel like this is the right spot
man personally i'd rather have a
cocktail filled with fresh ones we hunt
for more materials than we can eat
and freeze them over long periods of
time it's true actually
it doesn't human race gives terror a
whole new that is pretty [ __ ] up
he's not wrong is this a flying serpent
uh it's crawfish tail
onions bell peppers and celery the
absolute basics for any cajun
as we learned yesterday um the basics
for a cajun dish
is ice cream and chocolate sauce awesome
all into some sort of
paste if people actually buy this
garbage
even so i just made an internal promise
with myself okay
if i ever happen to come across any food
prepared with this
paste i vow to never call it cajun food
got it
okay cool story bro yeah good to know
where is this [ __ ] serpent and this
did i really come to find avery for no
reason
wait wait what is this and dewey just
more [ __ ] i don't care about
so now here's some real cajun cuisine
the way these sausages are linked up
they almost look like a serpent
but it's hard to imagine them let's move
on zach all right
all right
i'll talk to melvin because we like
melbourne
i'll keep okay oh i pressed a too
quickly
still not seeing any ooh
avery this box looks special it does
clarkson
food for their home
got it okay the toxins is this the
clarkson's family crest you have a
family crest
well okay i did meet mrs clarkson
yesterday the mother and she was
definitely a karen
but she was also hot and overdressed
which i feel like probably is the kind
of person who would have a family crest
oh so dragonfly it makes sense
yeah that's the clarkson's mark all
right
don't tell avery to go home he has a
very important job to do how dare you
um i want to make sure that youtube is
saying i'm playing the correct game
because sometimes it
sticks to whatever the last game i
played was ah it is correct
youtube never does that gg
all right ain't no big
deal though you can find those all over
town
okay is that so
well yeah they pretty much run all of
this town's major
i do believe they own just okay cool
so their word is law got it i'm picking
up what you're putting down
tyler here's the thing that you need to
know about york
he's passionate about everything so long
as he can actually someone with that
information
to be fair i love him adore him i've
said this before totally in um
videos or whatever that if i could have
an action figure of anyone
one is the hot toys uh
clawed from gta 3 which is now like
thousands of dollars
it's so good two francis york mode
tattooed with their dragonflies cool
can't even walk a few stiff
tram stamps zach
this dragonfly is our flying serpent
okay that's a stretch but the flying
serpent owns this town okay
they're related to lisa clarkson our
victim oh
and hoongan's oracle pointed us toward
their family crest
who hoongan's oracle for the record is
the painting in the hotel that spoke to
me
i was not high must be deeply
intertwined with this case well it is
their daughter
so you know melvin patricia
i think i've had enough of this frozen
world
let's head back out to that merciless
sun great
that uh well okay i feel like there are
a lot of leaps that happened there but i
again i learned from well part one stop
questioning it
i can't bear to spend another second
down here okay let's go
you creeps uh why is every ah ah
so intimidating god
loading screens that it happens it
happens
hello squid flesh who's the tiny girl uh
draft that is patricia
no way it looks like uh two other family
members are watching
this is why i stream on facebook for the
record so that my family can see it um
nick i am also streaming on youtube and
twitch
um but it is australian hours right now
and sometimes if i stream on facebook a
family member who knows nothing of
outside streams we'll see it which is
cool
oh floating on frozen
come on buddy come on ah there we go
there we go i finished ghost tsushima
not yet so sure i want to do it now
zach and i will take things from here
okay
then what should i do tend to your sick
wife
i don't know you're free to do as you
please
i'll stop by the sheriff's office when i
need your help again yes
uh melvin's wife is sick
patricia is his i guess adopted daughter
um and there was some like implication
that maybe melbourne's wife is already
dead i don't know
so there's already a lot going on if i'm
being honest that's what i'll do
then it'll sure make candy happy candy
that's right
but i am the sheriff of this town so i
do intend to get some work done
all right i know how about i search for
lisa's body while you're
that sounds great dude not a bad idea
brilliant actually
just be careful that you don't get
attacked by a barefooted giant
hey don't scare me like that
why do you keep talking about that giant
anyway you
really think some giant was responsible
for all well apparently someone who's 10
foot is the murderer so
i don't know silly of course i do
just when i thought you were starting to
catch on
disappointing to say the least
no one's catching on to anything you say
would you be so sure
i want to see some proof
for the record i am covering the thing i
do have to press
a to skip through dialogue so
proof number one it doesn't show you
that it's not just awkwardly pausing i'm
having to press a the footprints that
led up to where lisa's body originally
doc bane said we're made with bare feet
because the way everyone talks everyone
seems suspicious
you are correct and that is what i love
about this game
so far and the first game is that
everyone seems like they could be a
suspect and that is
genuinely super interesting to me
very into the premise of a town full of
probably motors and trying to figure out
which ones
of the feet were visible
oh that person who carried out lisa's
body must have had very large feet
and i'd say they were at least 16 inches
and they used to be in the cold
proof number two
i found fingerprints on the cord of one
of the hanging lights in the warehouse
the fingerprints weren't aimed up from
below they were coming directly from the
side
clearly the giant moved the light
because it was in his way he pinched the
cord with his fingers
i don't see what could go wrong
proof number three there was nothing
else found in the vicinity where lisa's
body was stored
this means the giant carried her out
without dragging her across the floor
that part i feel like isn't that hard
but there's only one set of footprints
because he
picked her up the only conclusion i can
draw from this evidence
is that a barefooted giant standing over
10 feet tall
carried lisa's correct yes that
concludes the entirety of my proof
any objections melvin but there ain't no
way a human that's why we're calling him
a giant
isn't it patricia okay have you seen
every human alive with your own eyes wow
we even actually her on that
she she's right and he couldn't let her
have it
well then you need to forget all your
preconceived notions when embarking on
an investigation
whether you come face to face with a
10-foot giant or
a skeletal gentleman you always need to
accept
everything that comes to you with a
clear mind alright here first ladies and
gentlemen it's true
do that and eventually the truth
will reveal itself to you patricia did
get
entirely right you're a smart kid i'm
sure you understand
well i'll be damned
i'm sorry i ever doubted you mr
ethos i special agent sir a
sharp eye and flawless observational
skills
uncovering the truth he's going to do
the hand thing again he does this hand
thing
into which please do it i won't ever
question you again i only did it once
i'll do whatever you say that's it
melvin
i'm glad you finally caught it i love i
would die for melvin okay
time to go patty also you started
calling this [ __ ] you met like two
hours ago
by a nickname and you're a grown ass man
so
you know this town well so i'd like you
to the questions from now on
and he's just like stealing
[Music]
dad's fine with it all right cool okay
zach we found the flying circle we sure
did dog we sure did
exciting stuff right now we simply need
to locate the ten maidens
the ten maidens are the bowling pins at
the bowling alley i got the alligator
with the hat
again everything i'm saying is true
the ten maidens uh i was told to find
them
by the talking painting in the hotel um
i found them at the bowling alley it was
like ten pins but there's this woman
who bowls there all day every day and
doesn't let anyone take the lane under
any circumstances ever because of
something to do with our husband
so we went to this voodoo store because
it seemed like she was superstitious
and bought an alligator with a hat and
now we're going to put the alligator in
the hat in her front yard in the hopes
that when she tries to go bowling i
don't know i guess tomorrow it like
stops her in her tracks to the extent
that she's not willing to bowl
because she's superstitious that maybe
the alligator in the hat will freak her
out
so then we can go bowling
nothing i just said was a lot
literally all of that was true that is
litter it's time to head on to alexis's
diner and league we've already been
there we've already done this
silly video game thought that i would do
the main quest objective first hang on
wrong button skateboard uh where do we
want to go
well i mean it wants me to go back to
the i don't think that i should though
[Music]
i don't know what any of the rest of
this stuff is we don't need to go to the
sheriff's department
no i can stop by the church that seems
like a cool thing to do
why not all right let's go
frank oh oh
bit of a drop there that's weird
uncommon
all right
oh another drop so so strange okay have
i passed it is that what's happened i
have
we gotta do oh squirrel oh several
well what is why are the squirrels red
on the map
what are you all
are they gonna are they gonna attack me
why on earth have you mocked the
squirrels on the map they are aren't
they
they stole my first and my lollipop
[Music]
squirrels
that's even worse than just attacking me
they stole my stuff did i just get like
picked on by
bullies
[Music]
i'll find this church i swear to god
[Music]
hello oh didn't i'm trying to run but i
guess i can't there isn't a run button i
don't think
nope just gotta walk at this exact pace
maybe i can't go in here yet
like why is the marker is it maybe at
the back oh the side door
is that what i'm going for
hello there's no exclamation point here
so i don't know if i can get inside the
church yet
which is truly devastating
it's true though um no the frame rate is
bad there's nothing to do with my pc i'm
playing this on a switch
the game is is is very bad um
not the the issue is not on my end to
the person who asked
um okay
so then what
uh church is closed i guess anyway bread
we can actually go to
as really freda was where i got the
whatever it is that i got i guess we
need to go back here that's where it
told me to go so
um the alligator in the hat was
absolutely afraid i keep pressing
um x instead of y because xbox
okay oh watch out for that
this town sure is peaceful zach yes
but that's why we're here to protect
this peace
isn't that right zach
i got stuck who what are you doing can i
get back up
oh i can't that's not ideal pavement my
worst enemy
ah why have you
designed this that way there we go
okay we're just slightly too high in
that one area
but that's one oh my god to protect this
piece oh look
i didn't either anything pretty sick
a lot of people on the streets i just
like feel very immersed you know
i really feel like i'm in the deep south
time that molten hot sun pours down
yeah don't use that again can we get a
south check
is that um is that a thing that you feel
when you're in the south
do you feel the molten hot sun on you
hey zach it looks like we were right on
the money tracing the san rouge
distribution route
right now yeah that happens in the south
got it okay thank you i appreciate it i
just need to sometimes
it's not from here sometimes just gotta
make sure you hear news about lisa's
murder
while sitting in a bar during our
vacation in new orleans that certainly
wouldn't have happened if we had stayed
in this oh that is why he came to the
car
he lied to everyone then um all right
i've already been here but it seems to
want me to be here again
[Music]
so
all right dog if that's what you want me
to do
no no
town really does look like an empty
department store you're absolutely right
what's up with the frame rate uh it's a
bad video game so
you know it is what it is
there's no main quest objective in here
i don't believe that this is what i have
to do we can go talk to this lady and
tell her to go on though i guess
this is the woman that i can't get to
leave the bowling lane
hi there handsome how's your day coming
[Music]
well i what do you mean make it to your
level you won't even let me bowl
no that wasn't the right thing to do
what should i do right now i can't
uh talk to the
didn't i already do that uh maybe it's a
cyclist it is
okay i can't she won't let me so i guess
i have to wait until
22 30 because i still can't bowl
because this [ __ ] won't leave this lane
um i could go do a side quest while i
wait for
the right time i guess so let's go do
this back to is really freda
nothing strange going on here just uh
a regular normal thing to do i can't
bowl you guys it's not an option because
she's on the lane i can't
leave um she won't leave brother i can't
make her leave
uh i know that's like a pretty big blow
but um it's not up to me i don't have a
say in the matter
devastatingly
all right well oh hey i had 420
000 uh uh youtube subscribers thank you
everyone
first rad hashtag blaze it
which is a thing that i don't do but you
know in for it anyway
give it a minute it's fine it's quick
i thank you everyone
uh did i make a new waypoint no
i'm going back to israeli freighter
well julie freida i think i'm saying it
wrong yes okay
a little skateboard time
great skateboarding jeans
it slaps
[Music]
what is this i will investigate whatever
oh
didn't mean to slow down as fast as i
did that let's check this out
one button stop pressing the wrong wife
okay
all right
really struggled under that fence i'll
see he just
he really puts his arse out when he
squats
he's like a duck you know ah excellent
it was completely pointless
that's cool
no worries from me
you make a video game however you want
and i will play it zach you're a coffee
person right
no sugar only milk yeah i'm completely
with you
okay this is gonna be it
do you see that what am i some kind of
cool guy
that's pretty cool all right
let's get i don't know a charm or
something made
uh is the character following me uh
she's a little girl
um she's the the town sheriff's daughter
and i guess i abducted her and
everyone's just like kind of cool with
it because i'm fbi
verily much shall serve thee well
great oh is this like crafting
oh i can get incense to boost my
skateboard abilities
bro yes
i really did not expect this to be in
this game
um
okay well why are they all just gun
capabilities
i want better skateboarding skills bro
who are you kidding no none of this it's
all just gun stuff
one of these two skateboarding abilities
[Music]
okay fine sure whatever i don't care
oh i can't oh i can't afford it because
i don't have
an alligator gar scale or low quality
beads
could i not have noticed um well i can't
do that then
great i have to get garbage
uh well then i don't know what to do
right now
i have to wait until 22 30.
there was a time passing mechanic in the
first game i wonder if like maybe i
because i don't smoke now because the
little girl is around she made me stop
smoking which
i think was the time passing mechanic i
actually don't remember exactly i'm
pretty sure it was he'd smoke to let
hours go by
i go back to the hotel
you do have guns in this game ryan you
do
[Music]
it is absolutely a thing
um known for its uh gun mechanics
actually
probably the strongest part of the game
um everyone's really raving about that
and the frame rate
so
you know just keep an eye out for it
it's good stuff
cool i don't remember what my gun's name
is but i think it's like something like
lieutenant alligator oh what am i
drinking
it's just apple juice it's not cool at
all no
i'm just trying to you know drink more
fruit juice so here we are
mr alligator that sounds right
i didn't name it for the record what
happens if i shoot these
impenetrable apparently okay what is
this m16
red on the map let's just go to that
because otherwise i'm directionless
right now
really upset that i didn't get to
you're a crazy person we already been
over this yes
i do have sugar
is there anything else you're going to
say
that's it i hope he says it again
did you know the streets i do not have a
po box
but thank you i don't think they exist
all it takes is some heavy rain there
are also a lot of places where large
trees were pushing up parts of the
asphalt on the sidewalk
those bumps were dangerous even when we
still had our car
i do the streets
that we can skate along
it is actually pretty cool that you can
just openly skate around this town
control this place yeah it's a good
example of how allowing certain people
to rise to power
can have positive effects as well also
don't you find that
southern people are remarkably friendly
that is true
both here in new orleans i've been
amazing
is it just the way things are down here
you certainly don't see that sort of
thing in new york or dc
they never stop to chitchat especially
when ordering food
they only say what's necessary without
any decoration
a customer only makes an icon i don't
want to cut him off so i'm just letting
him talk three times they interact
that's just how it is isn't that right
zach yeah i guess so
um okay where are we trying to go
is this her house maybe is that why i'm
here
because i have to leave the uh alligator
and it
she has bowling pins but for hedges
i'm gonna be honest here's the thing
that i would like everyone to
acknowledge about deadly premonition
the games are bad both of them but
they're actually not badly written
uh so while everyone is completely
insane um
and you know definitely got some
characters here
um yeah none of them are
badly written they are they are well
thought out the dialogue is absurd but
not
bad and i would prefer absurd damn it
dude
really gotta wait we need to place the
fig let's come back later
okay fine
i don't know how to make time pass is it
going in real time it's 10 42
it's now 10 44 so that probably wasn't
two minutes right
okay well let's just you know
check stuff out i guess while we wait
for it's definitely not real time
that is helpful
okay uh well
sure we could save why not
why not okay oh there's
not that many safe slots what is this
palm thing on the map let's go to that
i feel like if i go back to the hotel
it's that would be how i would skip time
but
you know i got so much exploring to do
you think of this
probably
[Music]
[Music]
i'm surprised he's letting me go this
far
all right we're gonna head down
what is that
what
what i mean
game just got ufos city now
oh i gotta beat i need to find more ufos
so i can make a necklace
incredible
oh my gosh okay i don't know what i'm
walking towards
oh is that a little girl or maybe it's a
grown person just scaled badly who knows
you look creepy though is this karen
you're terrifying you know that
yeah i think this is karen what are you
mrs clarkson hackerwood
she's really mean
uh when it's not story driven that you
are talking to
um when it's not story driven that
you're talking to someone there's no
dialogue it just
types it out on screen so here we go
okay you lost something
you think she'll be nicer if i find it
i i really don't care about you but sure
yeah i have so much time so
this is like shenmue level of time okay
shut up
she has the dragonfly on her we've seen
that from earlier
no just sounds like a toy
he jumps to conclusions that i
absolutely never would
is it is it a real doll or is it her
daughter her dead
daughter
now i don't know it was added to my side
quest log
who knows hello
cool suit you absolute [ __ ] chad of a
man
who is this guy
damn
so cool
i don't know aren't these people hot
didn't he just say that it was like
molten out here i don't know man
i don't know what's happening
oh that's useful what is this
louisiana iris bulb great that's what i
wanted what i wanted yeah
um okay
i wonder if i can go in this whatever it
is oh
trash
fbi love medium quality plate thank you
love to see it okay i guess the clock's
on this too i should have guessed that
being that she's outside
standing there can i steal the call
oh my god
nope all right back to my stupid
skateboard i guess
this is skateful you're right this is
exactly what i want from skateball
honestly
it's a i feel like twitch chat is
yelling about something but for the
record i
only see five messages at a time and i
see them from youtube facebook and
twitch all at once so
um i don't know what you're complaining
about
oh i'm gonna get rolled by some more
squirrels oh these aren't squirrels what
are you
do you think they're also gonna steal my
[ __ ]
they look like
maybe uh
i don't know what kind of animal you are
hyena maybe
wolf dingo it's like being back home
i don't know i also probably shouldn't
be going this way
there is nothing uh i think i want to go
back to the hotel which
is going to be casa pineapple i think
but i'm not entirely sure
all right let's go
let's roll i got places
b
uh i didn't actually say this is a
survival horror game distribution
because i don't know right two little
museums the first one is
this one may not be i don't know
i need things so i can make my necklace
to skateboard better
which makes sense to you i don't want to
upskirt the little girl don't make me do
that
okay stop car
uh this is not gonna have the range for
this correct
it does turns out also i like that they
all just sink into the ground rather
than actually appearing
video games okay let's keep going let's
keep going
[Music]
i'm just assuming i can pass time you
know again i actually have no clue
all right all right all right all right
all right
this town is actually pretty small give
it that you see the narragan is the
squirrel territory
no i don't care about wolves i just
don't want to get any squirrels
but that's why we're here to protect
it's getting repetitive i think that
means i've been exploring too much too
soon
they didn't script enough the amount of
activities and adventures that i'm gonna
go on
[Music]
oh yeah again the stream is not uh
not choppy um it's the game
uh it is not anything on my end this
game literally just runs like this
they shipped it like this
uh i guess i could go to the police
station maybe maybe that's what it wants
me to do
i could go talk to melvin at work
almost in ollie pretty dope if you ask
me
hello
[Music]
wait no this isn't even my hotel this is
a different hotel
maybe it is my hotel hello
it's a statue i've been fooled
all right just let me pass the time yeah
i'm thinking if i go to my hotel room
and i can like nap or something
i don't know we'll find out
i'll find out
i could use more of those ufos though
yeah the i think the frame rate's
perfect i don't know about you guys
should i go talk to the talking painting
again i think it was over here
it's not there anymore oh no
zack here's another perfect symbol of
the human condition
hunting trophy okay and it's a buffalo
hunting trophy
now that's a surprise i've seen several
trophies made out of human skin but
never a buffaloes
what
[Music]
well okay i guess he's in the fbi i i
can rationalize that
brings out this strange feeling from
within it's a terrible looking buffalo
you didn't even try
yes the very same feeling i got when
watching a certain film from 1984
directed by peter hiams 2010
the last scene in that film filled me
with such a sublime majestic feeling
all of us it was filled with everything
that was missing from the finale of 2001
a space odyssey
what just talking about it that's a take
again
damn okay let's watch it once we get
home promise session oh yeah i'll watch
that film with you
2001 and space odyssey is a great movie
though i like the ending so you can [ __ ]
yourself
uh my hotel room is up the top i think
maybe maybe maybe
the white doors perhaps are mine
i guess we'll find out
[Music]
no hey what y'all
doing in here um i don't remember which
room is mine
it seems odd that there's no thing like
on the door for it
uh is it this one no
it's not 301 no it is also
surely they'd let me go back in my room
it could be the second player i don't
remember
but um game vault guides i don't think
there will be a full
playthrough on funhouse um of deadly
premonition one i would
absolutely continue doing it but i think
we stopped after the last one
i really don't remember where my room is
that's it there we go
absolute tune in this hotel let me
okay can i nap
i would like to yes king size made in
france
zach even though the bureau is paying
for this it's still tiring to have to
live out of hotel rooms daily
pretty nice hotel room dude nothing
beats getting a good night's sleep in
your own room
can we sleep yes
okay
let's do it a good just
11 a.m to 11 p.m nap never hurt anybody
yeah this is a hotel room welcome
everyone
uh oh hey kraken it's um
beautiful ah 60.
congrats on that um still don't know
what this is or why it's here
there are a lot of options for things
that you can put in a hotel room
this technic technically
is one of them
so
that's all i have to say about that
do with that information what you will
all right i gotta go put this alligator
in a hat on this old lady's yacht
don't worry about it everyone
understands
let me skateboard there like a cool team
is patricia still following me
or does she go home to her parents at
night i don't think she followed me into
the hotel
every time there's a screen i'm like is
this did the game break or
it's still fine you would think that the
game is broken constantly but somehow it
isn't
um which you know we're very thankful
for
it's surprising but it does somehow run
okay
oh thank you mountain duncan i
appreciate that
uh yes commander jane shepard this game
is always this slow
um welcome
it is what it is uh yeah yes i'm
currently streaming on twitch
youtube and facebook simultaneously okay
let's go to this
all betty's house give her this stupid
gift
it isn't a gift it's actually that a
terrorizer um
not super concerned about it ethically
because she sucks and doesn't let anyone
bowl
in the town with one bowling league
[Music]
hope there
this is so ridiculous uh okay this one
i feel like this is what it looked like
no
think about this i'm talking about it
stop repeating yourself
is the skeletal gentleman you know
silence is okay you don't have to talk
about it exist outside the realms
this is it all right very excited to be
making progress
uh why does he not have a car he's in
the fbi
travels a lot so
uh you know
you know he just there's no point in
having one they'd have to rent him one
and i guess they didn't because
i think he is still technically on
assignment right now but
he came here by choice i actually don't
know if he's on assignment okay did we
do it oh
beautiful yes i wasn't kidding
oh my dear lost lane oh yeah
what are you doing there oh this
this is all part of the lease clarkson
murder investigation it
actually is something important hmm
oh yes very important yep
i'm fbi special agent francis york
morgan he's not lying please call me
york
that's what everyone calls me he's
actually telling the truth
what should i call you i am tyrone
sanders
pastor of the lucari evangelical church
i stopped by earlier and nobody was
there so
you suck at your job wow that's
aggressive
and what business does a pastor like
yourself have in a place
like this
well i live over across the way there
okay do you have an intimate
relationship with mrs carpenter
what why in the world all right that's
such a beautiful thing
what lord how could i
ever become intimate with one who is so
devoid of faith is she i feel like she
seemed religious she stopped coming to
church
oh she does all day that is true
she even pruned the shrubbery in that
danish pan i don't know what that is
yeah do i still work with one house yeah
of course i think my last video
went up like yesterday did you see that
hideous ox of a dog
pitiful with a capital p okay this is a
lot
but she shows no intention of changing
her ways
yes i feel she never lends an ear
when the good lord reaches out to you
okay i just asked if you had an
attempted relationship
intimate relationship with her i didn't
ask about any of any of this so you've
been spying on her
out of pity spying i'm merely awaiting
the chance to lend her a helping hand
okay you best be careful too this town
harbors much more danger than you're
aware of
yeah find yourself in need of salvation
feel free to stop by arch well now i can
go to the church so
that's what i'm gonna be doing for the
rest of the game
zach did you hear that he literally just
walked away pitiful
try saying that to someone in the city
what they'd instantly slap you with
slander or defamation charges
you'd be up to your neck and court
papers what are you talking about i
doubt i'll tire
of this town anytime soon where did that
come from i should consider stopping by
that church whenever we get a chance
what did he say that slit i don't what
he has so many takes that i don't expect
you know
the bowling light's not gonna be open oh
i had to unlock the church before going
there even though it was a location got
it cool
can't move right now are you gonna let
me move
happening here also
okay uh well
what's happening
uh well
maybe we did finally actually break the
game
um now i didn't think it was going to
break
i really thought it would run badly
um i didn't expect it to actually break
so am i gonna have to close the software
and lose my
is that does this game auto save it
moved
when did it when did it move
i can't
i can't open anything so um
no that's gonna be that's gonna be a no
uh
i could close it but i'm worried that i
will lose
maybe shouldn't have done that maybe
sleeping will have saved my daughter
come on
otherwise i'll be all the way back at
avery's
so that would suck
um i guess we'll find out
thank god for that okay it does have an
auto save function we should be fine
oh thank you i'm so scared of it
freezing all the time and it actually
finally did
okay let's find out where that auto save
is ladies and gentlemen
load game that's an auto save
that's i haven't placed i think that's
maybe just
is this the most recent one 23
yeah i think we just haven't placed the
thing yet
but everything else is fine could have
been a lot worse it could have been a
lot worse
everything's going to be okay as long as
we can get through that interaction and
not get cursed again
uh by the priest who i believe might be
in my
spot or whatever
oh boy
you know it's just you know you know
sometimes video games be video game
friendly reminder this game came out
today this game literally came out in
2020.
this isn't some like old games it's poly
ported or badly optimized
it literally came out today so just so
you guys knew that
okay let's try that again shall we just
it's just uh
it's a feature not a book to feature i
love that interaction so much
and the game knew so i get to experience
it again featuring not a bunch
don't worry about it this is
that could have been worse
um i'm very happy
don't mind me this is how i wake myself
you're insane dude
but so is everyone else so it's whatever
all right try again uh
to be fair you know
this cutscene probably is one of the
most like technically challenging things
we've seen in this game just yet
um like i get it it's
it's uh it's a lot of you know
interactions to load they probably
mocapped it so
just really animation lighting heavy
everyone's been saying like you know all
this technical did a post on it and
everything everyone's been saying it's
like crazy that
that it even runs an engine so it's like
not surprising that this happened god
i'm so sarcastic
i need help somebody help me i'm
definitely joking tyler
perfect okay oh
my dear love's lame i think i can skip
the whole thing
i hope this worked
yup great
great now can i move excellent
okay this game time is a flat cycle it
always continues to pass i like how i've
already passed time and it just told me
that i guess this is what didn't pop up
camping outside oh smoking is a mechanic
again
ah look we made it we [ __ ] made it
um okay we're gonna go to the bowling
alley i think
as is the main objective uh it's
probably closed right now though right
i do want to see what happens when that
old lady wakes up and sees the alligator
don't mind me this is how i wake myself
up squirrels don't steal my stuff
i don't have time
i need a bowl you don't understand
it looks like we were right on the money
tracing the sand rouge distribution
alley yeah it is okay i figured it out
they would have given the case to
another special agent
i hope she doesn't die okay
it's gonna be close though yeah it looks
close let's come back later okay
or we could smoke for 10 hours
if i knew how
that's the map
nope not that uh
okay maybe in here okay
do i have any cigarettes i'm looking for
cigarettes
yes
smoke do you think it's gonna pass like
can i smoke literally until morning oh
an hour at a time
oh i also need to eat zach how about we
grab a bite to eat what am i supposed to
do
i can think straight on an empty stomach
at almost midnight
mate do you have any ideas genius
have you seen this town
i'm gonna attempt a hotel i didn't need
to do that
let's see if we can eat at the hotel um
because we're hungry and then we can
sleep and then we can go back to the
bowling alley and we can fall tomorrow
you know we've all had these struggles
before this game's like if anything
really relatable right on the money
tracing the song rouge district stop
dude also i guess patricia does stop
following me at night
we shall show up again tomorrow morning
i don't know
i don't know what's happening
it's a good question how can they put
this on on switch but uh
not gta yeah this is way more
um technically challenging like for sure
my switch is overheating right now
it probably is which is you know no one
said this game is optimized all right
i agree boots more detectives should
skate
just yeah super into that okay i want to
see if i can still get food
enjoy breakfast well okay
yeah i'll take breakfast whatever you
have honestly
i think it's upstairs to the white house
good tune good tune they still kept that
soundtrack a plus for this one
can i eat
[Music]
no it's gonna have to be inventory based
i should have known
that that's what they would do didn't
mean pull that out
uh i'm forgetting how to menu it's why
for some reason it's [ __ ] it's x
actually
y on an xbox controller okay
yep let's have lollipop
[Music]
and alcohol okay did that not work
great um can't have anything in here
but i can come in here i need two
lollipops um so that's super cool what
is this is this edible oh can i eat you
please my restaurant serves only the
highest quality
i will take it let's do it
david which ain't too easy to find did i
hear wrong then
set me straight would you chef i thought
that cajun food was the norm in acadia
oh my god they keep talking about food
they just keep doing it
uh kately very unrelated but yes i liked
persona 5 a whole lot
why would you go out of your way to
serve creole food here when i was a
youngin
i trained myself at a famous restaurant
in
orleans a famous restaurant that's
incredible is it
he didn't even say what it was antoine
no don't tell me i got it
brennan's right none of those actually
but that place
taught me how to really cook going into
can i i'd really like to try something
oh can oh we can eat okay okay
okay
it's the cheapest so i'm eating ice
cream again i guess bananas and ice
creams matter with brown sugar and rum
it'll fill you to the brim that sounds
pretty legit i would eat that
again he eats everything out of a coffee
cup
it's cannon um they only serve soup
food and coffee cups here i see you
weren't lying about undergoing training
at that famous restaurant
okay the reason you save money you can
buy
ammo you can definitely buy food um
yeah i think it's just for purchasing
stuff you get money on some rigor
in order to gain such refined technique
you put so much care into preparing
everything just and your manipulation of
that low temp flame in order to bring
out such a pleasant fragrance
simply perfect oh he's such a wanker but
this is true
creole food you have to tell me now
which
famous restaurant did you train yourself
yeah
david come on chef we need to know zach
and i are begging you
ah you drive a hard bargain mister
ah i have to it doesn't ask me i'm not
gonna know
really oh just a hint now fine we'll
take it
it's the restaurant that serves the most
famous fried chicken in all of louisiana
crispy crunchy you know what i'm talking
about
bonafide fried chicken okay no you can't
this is so it's so weird to have a
conversation like this in a video game
that i clearly don't know what it's
referencing oh yeah but they just keep
writing
i'll bet they worked you pretty hard
mm-hmm you betcha so that's how you
acquire the mental fortitude necessary
to cook such
you guys think of popeyes i've never had
popeyes being that i'm not
you know american um
i feel like they're probably not going
to actually name it because that would
be a licensing problem
true it is fast food it's not a
restaurant
[Music]
so i don't know oh my time there taught
me just how tough city life really is
amazing zack did you hear all that
that's an
incredible story good story david you
really are a true chef
both zach and i have given you our
official approval
okay cool we ate now i'm gonna just go
back and sleep again even though i've
only been awake for like 20 minutes
uh because i need time to pass and i
only had one cigarette
oh god bless video games you know
it's so funny that right now i'm playing
this and playing ghost tsushima at the
same time
they could not be more different
okay let's
[Music]
try to sleep again hopefully it doesn't
stop me
we want to wake up at like seven right
sure like seven let's do it let's do it
as zack ever answered well if you played
the first game you would know
yeah good stretch all right boss i'm
gonna change your suit today you know
it's a new day um we're gonna go with
the agent suit
okay you didn't need to make out with
the mirror because of it that was
probably a bit much but
you know what self-love i take it back
you do you okay
let's roll
all right
uh karen yes the first game is also a
technical marvel i actually feel like
the first game runs a bit better than
this
um i don't know if
if i'm like misremembering but i feel
like this one is worse
and i feel like the first game even
looks better despite being significantly
older
so i don't know
this game got problems is what i'm
trying to say
that you said a lot there shyamalan is
edward but um
i love the first game it is literally my
favorite game
uh this one's grown on me a lot because
at first i hated it
do i still have the tattoo for the first
game yeah they're pretty permanent
i do yeah um
no i'm more on board with this one this
time around seriously where is patricia
is she just are we just not buds anymore
is that is that you patricia or are you
some other girl
that's not patricia cute outfit though
are you going bowling
i too am going [ __ ] bowling
i can't wait finally got rid of that oh
betty okay this is the deep sound
okay you wrote you know
a thousand lines of dialogue for
everyone else but not
exactly skateboarding
looks like a case of bad timing zach
when does this picture let's come back
excuse me i did all that
what are the hours it says on the owls
and that's what they are that why aren't
they involving lane
okay i guess it is pretty i maybe did
make it too early
is there anywhere that says the store
hours
oh who are these cool guys hanging out
what are you guys talking about is that
bill birth
look it's bill bo and
um yeah pretty much the same
hair model as every other female
character we've seen so far yeah let's
just save just for
posterity and then
i don't know wait some more what is
there someone that says the time
i'm on it dude i'm right here i would
love to do that too
can't do that yet i can't do that yet do
i i don't have any more cigarettes i
don't think
this one inventory is there anything
else that will pass the time
cola doesn't do [ __ ] i'm hungry again
well i guess i should go eat again
unless it opens at eight
just check just you know just in case
it opened today hell yeah dude
oh yes you love to see it
uh ridiculous
[Music]
for the week patty whatever
all right sass mail is mrs carpenter
here no
she hasn't come in today that's what i
thought everything's going according to
plan
yeah we gotta with that alligator in the
hat it's time to knock down the ten
maidens all right
bowling mini game
[Music]
okay let's do it oh my lord y'all are
back
yup listen up y'all ain't gonna believe
i think i will
i think i will what's wrong
mrs carpenter hasn't come in frankly i
feel like everyone in this town should
be worried that mrs governor is dead
she's been doing this all day every day
for forever
for the first time in 10 years 10 years
apparently
what could it be i will try to get some
strikes dave the guy
i will try i'm just hoping nothing bad
happened to her
yeah that would be my main concept she's
fine
you have my guarantee we don't know that
oh my
lord i reckon
if an fbi agent like you oh i should be
too
okay
[Music]
i can't wait to ball man you know what
i've been waiting for many games in this
game my whole the whole time
just you know do something other than
skateboarding or talking we'd actually
be pretty sick
it was that one time i move crates
around value is a relative thing
we needed to find that figurine
[Music]
oh my god i'm so ready
[ __ ] yet also i don't know what's going
to happen after this i think this is as
far as i can give like
i'm aware of the story though like in
that
this is my second objective from
whatever his name is
hound doll it's a pokemon whoever he is
they don't have bowling alleys in the
city no more
wrong patty i love the way you
condescend patty
i have absolutely no interest wrong
patty tossing a heavy ball at lined-up
pins
where's the fun in that okay mate you
can't even call this a sport
it's a game for cavemen okay he actually
her and then was just so mean
nonsense utter nonsense okay
then can i throw the ball instead
absolutely not patty this is part of the
investigation
i need to do this myself no matter how
stupid at least you've acknowledged that
you're the one who's stupid sick butt
sure looks like you're having fun to me
bowling mini game i would love to
sure thirteen pounds sure whatever um
i mean i feel like we maybe like wanna
sort of like that
oh uh okay [ __ ]
okay this can be a little hotter than i
expected i think
i can do it i can do it
you call that a failure i didn't get a
strike but damn
okay
oh this is going to take a while
not a failure it's three pins left is
not a failure
all right okay i think we intentionally
spin
probably
i didn't though did i i just did the
same thing
that was worse you don't have to tell me
i'm a failure every time
okay so getting an exact strike is gonna
be real tough so here's what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna go
this way and then in theory i would have
to curve left right
do that
maybe
what
16 pounds let's do heavier let's go
heavier we're gonna go back over here
oh there's an angle adjustment oh
oh okay why did they make this so
complicated
that's too much spin
oh
okay i've really felt like that was the
one but apparently it wasn't
[Music]
probably too much spin
thank you oh
first try can't believe i got that on my
first attempt that's crazy i was so good
at that
why did they make that so complicated
you left the house the alligator with
the hat didn't stop on that bad why did
they make it so technical
i mean i respect it but i'm very
confused
[Music]
oh my god okay great that was just a
stroke of luck mrs carpenter
despite how i may see i've never been
any good at any of the balls
for yourself i tried you're on our
planet quite hard
oh no you can't fool me
i can tell the fbi is giving you that
yeah we got bowling training
that's what's up if i gave you a few
lessons good point
miss trojan they did waste a lot of time
on that bowling game and making it
perfectly precise that they could have
spent on the frame rate
i'm glad they didn't semi-pro
that's right that's what i said not pro
but semi-pro yes you suck
yes semi-pro you did fail like three
times dude you'd
never be able to go pro you don't have
what it takes okay i'm allowed to insult
him
you want you could become a semi-pro
if you tried really hard though cool
thanks i guarantee
cool come back and see me when you feel
like i don't i just needed to do that
for some reason
she's just gonna let me borrow her lane
what do you think will happen if her
husband finds out
you can't just walk around offering to
let men
borrow your lane dude what the [ __ ]
well we gotta give youngsters a chance
to grow
that's what we always say nice i could
actually oh my god why are you still
talking about this i take her words with
a grain of salt devour you
it's still happening patricia
i can understand why you'd be he's such
a [ __ ] [ __ ] to her
but you don't need to you shouldn't have
to feel inferior every time you look at
me
oh my god york
this is what happens when you don't have
friends i think
i'm speaking about myself obviously you
sure
you don't need to get your head checked
out that was a fair comeback
it's so strange zack i feel like
i'm discovering a new side to myself by
the way
oh my god i just came here because the
guy in the painting told me to
topple the ten maidens i just want to
get further on the murder mystery you
know
[Music]
you said you're investigating the least
sparks an
incident i am yes in that case
excellent excellent that poor girl lisa
she was a drug drucky and she was
into the really pants like what
panadol red powder oh
you already figured out that much well
the reason police
turned into such a little hoodlum what
does that mean
can i get a south check please everyone
anyone from the south is
little hoodlum a thing that is set in
the south
um can you please let me know it's just
you know sometimes i really just need
your assistance on figuring out
if things are from the south or not um
so that's
yes little hoodlum yes okay got it i
again i thought it was hoodlum
but she's saying hoodlum that's my
particular
south is the pronunciation the south
that's the south check
you got it
[Music]
some no's some yeses i'll take it the
south is still canon
japanese game developer creates the
south perfectly
galena can't believe they did it they
recreated a puffing simulation of the
south
all right sorry just thank you i
appreciate the help i gotta get back to
the game
you know you guys understand as far as
i'm concerned she's still nothing more
than a child herself
okay dressing up in
fancy clothes oh she's talking about
karen always out on the town
somewhere whose name i really have
already forgotten didn't we just talk to
her
children giving birth to children
if these aren't the end times well i
don't know
you're not even gonna bring up the
alligator in the hat that i left on your
front lawn
that took effort dude oh and they were
always cooped up in that jazz bar
kalina wouldn't know proper parenting
that's it
that's it skeleta zack
the jazz ball this jazz bar or the first
game we first heard about it from
patricia she's right there
it must be deeply connected with this
case i think it's very polite that
everyone just lets him sort of talk to
himself and they all just sort of like
without saying anything they're
literally staring at him well patricia's
eyeline's probably a bit off
but she's dead inside so red powder it
must be
sandwich i wonder if the red powder is
at all related to uh
the green bale case from deadly
premonition one
following the oracle and filling the 10
maiden sure paid off didn't it
so mr special agent are you often well
since you negged me about going semi
[ __ ] pro
yeah i think i said this is carpenter
thanks to you i've gotten a new lease
why doesn't francis just ride a car um
he likes to be called york that's what
everybody calls him
um and i think that
it's preferable he doesn't he doesn't
like both the the
roads being bumpy so oh then how about
you mosey on and let me get back to my
back okay
i need to bowl my first game of the day
or else i'm gonna get rusty great
well what are you waiting for get a move
on shoe
shoes did she i wanna it looks like she
maybe added the alligator with the hat
to her
dolls i'd really like to check on that
she didn't
that's i mean it took me a long time
so just a huge bummer
what you can't leave
screens black for this long in this game
or i'm gonna think everything's broken
you can't who [ __ ] knows is it
loading
is it broken
what just happened
is the terror in not knowing if the game
is broken or not
because no it was hoongan who is um
the guy from the painting that spoke
i am a bit spooked to be fair
i mean there was supposed to be some
kind of transition here for hoongin
[Music]
i'm not touching it okay
i should have been listening to that
though he gave me more clues
zack it's another yeah what did he say
can you repeat that for me it appears
that we're being guided by a mysterious
power [ __ ] what up
this oracle is a simple one okay cool
the false altar you already know what
this is right that's probably the judge
a place where lisa oh of course no yeah
i knew that that's
uh you meant it's actually really rude
of me to say the church
yeah that's um of course that that's
what i
a think at some sort of altar as if she
was being worshipped
that's what chef david said right
cool
well yeah it's literally the sun awakens
refers to dawn of course okay
catch he said when the sun awakens catch
the tip of the baby
bear's tail at the false altar so i
guess
at sunrise i need to go to and the tip
of the baby bear's tail
is the north star oh at dawn
look straight to the north from where
lisa's body was found i don't like any
of that
why did they make him do that i don't
like any of that
that's the thing that they put in that
it was a choice that they made
oh my god okay yeah on the surface this
oracle may seem tricky
convoluted but it's still mere child's
play
didn't think it was convoluted or
difficult at all actually um we're all
on the same page there your
you don't have to be a pretentious
douchebag about it i love you though so
feel free to if you would like i'm still
very good at my books
all right zach let's follow
um people keep asking about who zack is
you find out at the end of the first
game so i don't want to tell you
[Music]
it is sort of part of the appeal
that you are constantly asking who the
[ __ ] is zack
and what are you talking to um dr
defrosty i look at both chats at once as
well as facebook they're all in my
in the same screen so i see all chats at
the same time but yes i'm not gonna tell
you
well i could spoil it for you but i
don't want to because literally
it is a thing that zach is supposed to
be
a mystery for you so i don't know what
other world refers to but i'm sure we'll
find out once we okay well it's not
sunrise
that's right patty this case is a rather
complicated one
so zach and i are following oracles
given to us by a skeletal gentleman in
order to crack it
don't ask questions don't worry about it
don't worry about it
okay it's gonna be six a.m
i don't have anything else to do um like
i mean i can't do any of this stuff yet
so i just gotta what am i supposed to
just go sleep all day again we could eat
actually i can't do this yet because i'm
not sunburned
which is devastating because what it
looks like it does
is make you hot if you're sunburnt
so unless that's false advertising
i think i need to get some um okay let's
eat something different today oh
coming right up honey i haven't even
said what i want yet
okay uh we had the chocolate sundae last
time and they spoke about it for
[ __ ] five hours slice up duck fried
with veggies and hearty southern meal
made from shrimp and short
sure do you make that for me it sounds
great
i could fall till 6am you're right
does she also put that in the coffee and
he does this thing with his mouth very
come back anytime honey
i feel like i'm doing it
you know
when he eats all of his meals out of a
coffee cup you ain't gonna find any
better cajun food and all i know we
already spoke about this
oh [ __ ] thank god uh okay
well i don't have anything
to do so
we are safe slots wait
why are this many auto safes
okay i don't need to save that's what
i'm learning feels weird but i don't
need to do it
seems like a thing that is not
necessarily oh i should find some ufos
to shoot your right pop-tart kitty
that's a good idea i need beads so i can
get better at skateboarding
yes
hopefully those [ __ ] squirrels really
came at me
all right not a lot extreme
copied straight from ghost of tsushima
again
taking your red leaves you know i
thought they had that
monopoly but apparently not apparently
not oh thank you
sex pizza thanks
hello uh this is
this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me it's daddy
hurry up and answer yes
would love to this is dc
eagle i read you loud and clear
i'm sure
there's no point in using code names if
he's just going to say my real name
yeah you say that to his daughter
[Laughter]
mr york can you hear me patricia is me
at this whole game
oh [ __ ] hell
dc eagle to lucare tiger is something
wrong
over
i miss york i got so much so
[Music]
okay just sit tight and listen okay hell
yeah dude
you got it roger wilco go right ahead
over i just happened to overhear some of
the clarkson's talking on another champ
[ __ ] oh you're right his thumb is really
long
damn
you're referring to galena the social
butterfly karen
over yes another special agent
slam dunk melvin rules he we don't
deserve
melvin york doesn't deserve melvin you
know i don't think anyone's ever been
less deserving of someone that positive
and playful so you already did a little
research on her huh
that's right the one who's gone missing
is the younger of the clarkson sisters
he's perfect
you know
bless you my proverbial hat goes off to
your investigative skills sir
anyhoo galena used to be an actress
and she's also real pretty in the face
draws attention wherever she goes
but she's also real pretty in the face
i'm gonna start describing people that
way she's real pretty in the face
would you let me know i already have she
told me to find a doll or some [ __ ]
oh yeah over
this is incredible wait oh hey mr york
what do you say we cut this out huh okay
it all seems kind of overblown probably
you can definitely be pretty in places
other than the face
yeah but i like she's real pretty in the
face
for a woman who is pretty much hot
everywhere we saw her earlier
i reckon we're the only ones listening
to this okay melvin
no need
yes melvin i agree there's no need for
us to cling to
it formalities ain't never been too good
with formalities you feel me
what does that mean
if melvin's the murderer um this is the
worst game i've ever played
in all other circumstances it's one of
the best
good luck out there but if he's the
murderer it's literally the worst
and i will give up daddy's place
he's the best patricia okay okay sweetie
i okay if this game is going to be this
game
i expect that the next line york says is
firm
disagreement with patricia patty do you
think galena is really as beautiful as
people say it wasn't
i at least she let he let her have that
one
i don't know i guess it's pretty hard
men just seem to like women like her for
some reason
she's hot yeah who's more beautiful
galena what the [ __ ] york what
what what is okay yeah thank you
patricia voice of reason
candy woods your mother melvin said she
was
the prettiest girl in town how should i
know
well i think my mom's pretty that's a
stupid question oh okay patricia
why is it stupid my mom is sick
okay
zach that was a bad move
what happened
we stepped right into a private matter
without you just asked a little girl if
she thought her mum was pretty i don't
think that that's that bad
like mostly i am on patricia's side
at all times because of her relationship
to melvin
but in this case i think she was things
are bound to happen
after all and especially well-rounded
not predictable
don't pronounce every organization out
there that's more well-versed in the art
of infringing on people's privacy
okay yeah oh my god
all right so we can't go to
the spot yet
right let's go over here
what is the objective then
it says there is one
i'm just gonna go towards whatever it
tells me to it probably is the objective
site but
no why not
yeah i'm in agreement nobody's on team
york in this situation
hey zach it looks like we were right on
the money
nope the same one he said that was right
to louisiana
you know i could check
we have planted the the alligator with
the top hat
for the maidens or whatever if i go here
ain't that gonna be her house i want to
see what if alligator is moved
oh you are first more ufos
i love the idea that anyone joining this
stream at any point
just makes absolutely no sense even
though the game makes no sense by itself
anyway but i feel like
just the later it gets the weirder it
gets you know okay we're gonna i'm gonna
go to the level one here
once again i need beads to make my
skateboarding whatevers
so i get better at skateboarding don't
worry about it
are they coming down
it's gonna be too far away
there we go why
you know you know you're not even
looking at it
oh he got it okay gun was not pointing
there
what is it high quality bead
i'll take it the others look too high
like i can't get those
right surely i can't get those
um yes sony pericles pericles
they are uh ufos
don't worry about it so it'll be good
okay i just want to see if the alligator
and top hat
is still here
just you know just curious what she did
with it
she moved it
surprisingly let me do that looks like a
case of bad timing well we know where
she is come back late
okay um
i'm gonna keep going to the objective
even though i think it's probably not
the right time of day to do that
maybe it would have been it'd say four
to six i think
i think so yes look well it's an
alligator or a top hat catch up would
you
all right get on board one moment
i don't know i don't understand the
source of your computer
uh this is basically like both a prequel
and a sequel
is what they are calling it
this is before did you first
all right it is it is trying to make me
go here and i can't go here yet
i don't have anything else to do um i'd
like to go to that jazz bar that
everyone keeps talking about
is that the owl's nest
six probably right
so ah it's but it's not telling me to go
there yet so i just feel like it's
probably not
the thing it wants me to do what is this
[Music]
i there's nothing to do
um
in the time between i should go buy
cigarettes is what i should do
you can only spend one at a time
in new orleans you keep repeating
yourself my dude you know just getting a
bit much
okay it's pretty much just one main road
i don't know why i keep getting lost
or how
that you're a coffee person right yeah
no sugar
yes i'm completely with you thank you
i guess i'm gonna sleep again um but
mostly i'm gonna try and buy cigarettes
so
i got worried that the game broke
[Music]
who is this
what is this okay
damn all right how did you do that and
off of one
who is this cool guy
hey you you're fbi right yeah
who might you be i'm raving
but around here they call me the
speedway i hate it
what's up
you're here investigating the lease case
yeah yes and instead of a car
is this the part where i start driving
for real
you've already become the talk of the
town i don't want to though anyway i was
just wondering if you needed any help
what's your name i'm fbi special [ __ ]
video game man
please call me yours okay it is
oh [ __ ] he smiled at him i'm actually
testing out a new kind of business right
now
you try to [ __ ] and i was hoping you'd
be down to try it out yorkie
what kind of business calm down speed
[ __ ] i drive my customers to wherever
they were she's like a taxi
in this tiny town i gotta think about it
i reckon it ain't much different from a
taxi
have you seen my skateboard dude your
type of business then
are you stupid because you haven't heard
the details yet
why would i let me explain okay
i got a feeling that in the future cell
phones
are gonna get more advanced people are
gonna be able to just
order taxis from their phones whenever
they need to get somewhere
so i'm thinking hey why don't i just
start a company that
instantly sends out drivers to take
folks from point a she's inventing
got it great how i want to make it so
that
anyone out there can just register on my
site as a driver
why did they film the need to do this
not pros then once we get there
we'll just send out the driver who's
closest to the customer was there a ride
a stream
a hell of a lot more convenient than
public transportation well they
the logo will be a y and a v cool yeah
oh that's the fast travel on the map
what they're explaining to me is fast
traffic
is independent it's fast travel i reckon
it'll work out got it
see that means it's driving because i
figured it out bound by their own
private agreements
my company will just provide them with a
platform to hook up
squeaky clean right it's fast travel
and i'm actually sorted out here comes
the fun part
i want to help you get around while
you're smoked and it was just tits
four feet of course
keep an eye out for my balloons oh it
all does make a little more sense
give me a whistle and i'll be there
great
why not invite me to use your sight then
why are you out here driving around
i'm still experimenting with this
business model
my side isn't i'm the best i'm still
trying to figure out what sort of
fees will work best
customer to get a feel for how things
will really go
all right well you want to ride
zach that was quite the spiel wasn't it
it
seems like little more than a scheme to
make some pockets oh i missed the
scratches bring those back what's new
about that they were too short-lived
although it's back to we had idioms to
keep investigating here for days with
nothing but a skateboard
disagree what do you think should we
accept their offer
i don't need to go anywhere but sure
i literally there is nowhere to go
that's what i'm talking about come on
get in get in give me a ride on them
titties
i don't need to go anywhere we've been
over this
i mean
you know that's the problem
sure
it's interesting that fast travel costs
you money
also seriously there there is a boss
fight at some point in this game
but i don't know when or where any of
that kind of content takes place
um sorry was i too pervy to the woman
can't help it i don't know what you want
from me she was hot
aina
okay the ball fight is bowling
well i didn't need to do that at all so
um
you know maybe i can make a charm now
with the stuff that i've gotten from the
ufos
again a real sentence about a real thing
that actually happened in this video
game
don't worry about it
it's all so ridiculous but i also love
that like again
i think it's not badly written it's just
absurdly written
so it's all [ __ ] insane
but it all makes sense like i i still
understand what's happening
and who these people are
you know they they done did it they done
made a video game okay charms
please i want to make one can i make any
i need low quality beads you don't want
to try to tell me your bitch-ass beads
[ __ ]
that's a bummer still nothing
at least i got that cash fit catfish
tail
all right i can see it
thyroid it's super dude i have so little
to do
thou hath discovered the very purpose of
my emporium
that year wait what does that mean is
that a threat you threatening me
that's the thing that i have in my room
the hotel for some reason
okay let's go
nowhere nothing for me to do i'm gonna
sleep again i guess
so just go back to sleep
i suppose
you know uh
my mighty bush basically swerry who is
the
director of this game i believe zp at
least
i think he's still director of this one
who also made the first game is also the
writer
so yes the developers of the game did
allow the writers to make it
um yeah writers are still devs though
too obviously
but uh yes that is basically what's
happened here yes
uh yes this is skateful i might just
because it would be funny
the next time that i stream this game
just put on twitch that it's skateful
you get in trouble for that i don't know
you don't own a mixer um
that's where i should be streaming all
right i just have to go back to the
hotel
i have played disco elysium eagle it's a
[ __ ] great game
[Music]
i'm gonna talk about video game writing
it's deadly premonition too
disco alicia everything else
all right guess we're gonna sleep
forever then i don't you know
play video games to experience my
real life just all over again but here
we are
[Music]
just keep i keep doing it so my goddamn
gta we play
don't worry about the frames it's a
feature okay stop it's
a feature it makes it enhances the
experience makes it more emotive
cinematic
okay so stop all right don't worry about
it
thank you hamid you're right they all
speed lines
um is there a law reason for the
skateboard yes
um he stopped enjoying driving after
going to new orleans because the roads
were all busted up and he finds
skateboarding to be
better is sort of what happened
so yeah we're just gonna go to sleep
again
until what time
all right let's wake up about five this
really is like my real life
when that cfs is bad all we'd be doing
is taking naps let me tell you
i would like to wake up at wow it's only
8 30 i'm gonna
okay okay
it's six right yeah we wake up five
that's fine 5 30. that's fine that's
fine
matthew cars made the frame rate drop
way more so they chose skating
no i think they would have kept the
cause if not the case i think they would
have uh
appreciated that [ __ ] off patricia
i'm that hungry damn okay
oh i guess every time i sleep i have to
pay a fee too that is a bummer
all right we're gonna just go get a
little bite to eat
um and then we're gonna go to the
gravesite
okay it's not a big deal i know what's
happening
this makes perfect sense
[Music]
uh shyamalan s wood you should play
um play double find games if you like
the games you listed
there and that's what i'm talking about
try double fine
you can't get fine eaten like this and
then so make sure you enjoy
okay uh
i had that last time so today i'm gonna
go with the fresh barbecued and juicy
i'll stuff for you
it'll stuff you i'm bad at reading when
i'm tired it's a thing that happens and
bad at speaking
so again just a coffee mug
it's one of my favorite things about
like yakuza does it
persona for sure does it um
wow uh i thought that i cut myself
earlier on a butter knife and i actually
did i was like surely that knife's not
sharp enough to cut me but i really do
have a cut on my hand
um it's just a butter knife
uh yeah they actually animate the foods
this game you just get the same [ __ ]
coffee cup all over again so
i literally did cut myself in a butter
knife yeah
yeah yes
it's not like bleeding but it's like a
paper cut like
we really don't did that it's while i
was cleaning
all right time to go to that grapes not
gravesite
the altar or whatever of of false altar
boss worship i don't know i don't know
it makes sense
less role less role
they animated his smile too much i don't
know if that's the problem with his
smile
i don't know if that's the issue um
a couple of things surrounding his smile
that i have problems with and i'm not
sure of animating in his problem
i don't know who lee pace is
i am a mess it's true yeah that's you
you're not wrong
ooh
[ __ ] what
okay this is some deadly premonition
[ __ ]
mr alligator not sure how much okay
in this situation but i guess you're
better than nothing
what the [ __ ] what
the zack i don't even need to say it do
i
this is right out of that movie video
drum
1982 directed by david cronin what
at the time it was seen as a hard movie
to digest for normal movie goers
but now it's become a yeah this is fine
i always just saw it as another weird
canadian movie but
this changes everything my arm and my
gun have become one
now i can really understand what max was
going through what the [ __ ] dude
okay hold down the fire button to charge
the psycho gun
aim it towards an enemy to lock on and
then release the fire button to fire a
homing bullet i mean it sounds pretty
sick
faster your firing speed the faster your
gun will lock on
okay i think i understand maybe
what in the [ __ ] well
not jesus christ the framerate is not
good for any of this
oh my god the sounds
i'm not clear on what you want me to do
oh i see wait why didn't it work
did y'all [ __ ] off please i'm trying to
figure out the garbage mechanics
if y'all could just um
no
oh it's hold down the stick
nope do it more than once i don't feel
like that tutorial gave me all the
information that it said that it did
so we go
nope stop not firing definitely not
firing for some reason
i'm not firing when i press the firing
thing
if it wants me to hit zr i feel like i'm
doing that you know
we go walk on
oh i just have to let it go when it's
still
oh great
okay i think i understand i just have to
let it go
sort of like when it's just hit it
this well they're going to spawn
infinitely so what in the [ __ ] is this
oh my god no
skateboard away stop sniffing at me
this changed a lot you know um
to be fair the first game is kind of
like that too then but wow
um i didn't
okay okay
truly the room of video games
it's uh it's saying snip for sure better
than resident evil 2
absolutely dude that re2 remake ain't
got [ __ ] on this
um and i just don't know why they made
the combat
that rather than just regular shooting
um i preferred when the squirrels were
my main enemies
frankly
but you know we can't vegas can't be
jesus can't win them all folks
i feel like just every now and then i
like take a second to process how
batshit insane this is and i go
yeah okay um yeah okay this is happening
oh nice choice i don't want to [ __ ] with
any of you right now
do i have to do this in the next 10
minutes ah
oh that's just an actual venom oh so i
could do that too
yeah that's way better that's so much
faster why did why would i ever use the
other one i [ __ ] spawn infinitely man
at least i'm a skateboarder that's what
i'm gonna have to do for the next
in-game
seven minutes is just be a cool
skateboarder guy
[ __ ] hell you're absolutely right my
mighty bush just when i was like yeah
things are getting normal um
the painting blacked out my game for
like a minute and
uh i'm just gonna go to the false altar
or whatever
don't worry about it and so i had to
sleep for 20 hours and the hotel charged
me 150
and i was hungry again um and i was like
this totally is making sense everything
is clicking for me right now
and then i walk outside before 6 a.m and
this is what happened
because it was also sensible before it
spawned
uh endlessly spawning demons with
scissors that yell snip snip
cut cut at you
so you know
all right just one more cool guy
skateboard around this block
and it should be 6 a.m there we go thank
you
what the [ __ ]
i don't [ __ ] understand what's
happening uh
it's like are they just gonna drop that
on me
are they gonna try to explain it because
you know there's no reason that any of
that should be like that
it doesn't make sense thank you
oh he does harm the song from the first
game
usually there's music playing when he's
humming so i can't hear it and i heard
someone
comment saw someone comment that last
time but i didn't realize it was true
okay what are the x's
items do you think they drop things they
can help you make cool charms
keep popping today and i don't know why
i've had like entirely vegetables the
whole day
all right all right it's the false ulta
okay well oh great cool we did it we got
it we got it
it's gonna be fine
oh he sounds like an anime villain
that's the bad guy
that's the 10 foot tall giant who killed
it
no just transported her perpetrator
decide to enshrine lisa's body here
question my dude good question
cool casual turn i too turn around like
this
what why is this happening now
remember this oh thank you miss amy i
love that i'm awake during
where i'm streaming during australian
hours right now stone skipping
we did it all the time when we were
killed for some reason i could never
beat you
but i feel like i've got whatever all
right now i don't
i i thought we came here to investigate
but
i guess not um
if i were to like give this game a box
quote it would be i guess not
or why um but like enthusiastically
take a trip down memory lane sure dude
sure is another mini game
this game is [ __ ] padded content for
days value for money
i don't trust the tutorials anymore
because that last one was full of [ __ ]
okay oh we have to select stuns
okay
okay great cool sounds easy
sure okay so how am i supposed to know
what the timing is
cool bad all right
sorry i describe myself in bed okay
let's go let's keep going
cool and then bad in the bad oh i still
got a lollipop anyway
yes i would like to skip again
no there was just as fun as when we were
kids
i would like to try again i had to
what's that
for [ __ ] sake you can't you know
introduce that and then
no wonder the word mississippi means
father of waters
it has the power to carry boats down the
tiniest of tributaries
okay dude it's one of the prime symbols
of america's majesty
the vitality of the human race okay bro
now about that boat
what sort of cargo would give it such a
deal there is literally no draft
what else do you see yeah there's a
skull in the water i saw it clearly if
only for a second
oh the dragon yeah no but there's
definitely a skull in the water
i'm not crazy this town never wants to
stop reminding us about the clarkson's
just dab at the skull though or are we
gonna
can i stone skip again i would like to
try that one more time yeah
yeah good
cool all right let's try it again
oh great no too soon it's harder than it
looks
we're going to do it again though i want
to get better at it
and the stones are also different sure
okay
all right we done did it i think
well the end ones are hard i'll take a
nine i'll take a night that's
you you uh we'll put it on your merry
way we did it
we did it sunscreen
oh my god they really be talking about
getting burnt in this game a lot huh
um no we're actually okay i will return
to that though excellent mini game thank
you
okay cool more investigating less
looking at votes
zach do you remember the oracle uh yes
when the sun awakens catch the tip of
the baby bear's tail stop at the phone
you don't have to do that and the
entrance to the other world you super
don't have to do that in other words
we need to go to where lease was found i
wonder what we'll see
singularity inspection yeah
i've been looking at that thank you it's
a skull zack
as clear as that catch up your jesus
that's the spot
the barrier between our world and the
other oh is that where the comet's gonna
be is in the other world
one might call it a singularity got it
right
oh oh i oh
i didn't mean to finish i was other
things to look at
i am too good at game you know now
it's a problem why did you leave me
behind
you're not supposed to investigate
without me some people think they have
real struggles but have you ever tried
being too good at game
because you know sometimes
means you don't get to inspect a crime
scene
so i'm pretty sad about that
what's up patricia oh
i'm sorry patty hey you just missed a
special moment
what moment all right chill
yes you can't see you press stay too
quick all i see
is the clarkson's plantation and that
gross silence silo is fine
there you have it zach patty zach and i
will take it from here
in the meantime you need to head home
and wait for us okay we're going to some
other whole
world alone yeah yes but only for a
while
you could go hang out with your dad i'll
contact you again hey
hold on also would you mind telling
melvin that i'm heading to the sugar
cane plantation
i'm sure we'll need his help later whoa
agent york
wait you're really gonna leave a little
girl like me here all alone i mean you
came here by yourself all alone you're
probably find patricia
act like an adult for once in your life
oh right i promise to protect you from
all the evil
okay you promised protect me
i think you're fine dude i feel like if
you come with me that's going to cause
more problems
you'll be fine thank you yolk thank you
you finally said something that i agree
with
you made it this far alone didn't you
exactly
she clearly did not do that her mouth
moved
like she was talking all right
[ __ ] off patty so what am i doing
heading to the singularity
tight let's do it i can't wait is it
only going to be open between
the hours of
red um dumb [ __ ] whatever and
and and and dead man scissor boys
o'clock or are we just gonna be able to
do this one
skateboard
it's weird that it looked like it was on
the river like right next to me and now
i apparently have to cross the river and
head to the sugar planet
but whatever i'm not going to question
don't mind me this is
superior game design oh okay didn't
expect to bounce off of that
narrowly avoided that one okay it lit
really
okay no it's fine stop asking questions
a lot stop asking questions
hello it's another ufo
yes
oh a medium quality
plate [ __ ] yes dude
it's so this game more than any other
game i've ever played is so aggressive
about cutscenes or like showing you
information
in the middle of something it doesn't
fade in it just
every time catches me off guard
oh hello oh hi cool boots cool guy
it's a nice black shack we're about to
encounter a new character great
oh damn it danny oh i saw her go inside
but it's empty clock's in the hell's
going on here
you won't be able to find the other
world
who in the hell are you what are you
doing on our plantation
i'd like to ask you the same i'm
you can't just do that well if you don't
want to tell me then i have
oh my god okay i just said this is our
plantation
i assume that means you're a member of
the clarkson correct and you're here
too there's a search being conducted on
clarkson property
it must be a search for galena clarkson
who's gone missing
judging from the way you speak your age
and most of all the color of your eyes
you must be danny clarkson the father of
the victim
galena's husband oh and the manager of
the cold story he seems way too young
nice to meet you i'm fbi special agent
francis york morgan
i'm here investigating the least
clarkson case
oh and just in it that's what everyone's
always called me
you think i give a [ __ ] you better watch
your mouth or i'm liable to whoop your
gut
i really did not expect this dude to be
a dad but um
here we are you're just perhaps taken
from you and now your wife has gone
missing
the close-up on his eyebrows is
obviously true uh i imagine you're doing
everything you can
dramatically but
danny listen to me it won't get you
anywhere
no matter how hard you search you'll
never find them
every character in the game is handsome
you want to throw down with a clarkson
absolutely not i simply wish to solve
this case
then hurry up and investigate god damn
it i am
that's why i'm here the oracle told me
there's something in this spot
oracle that's right zach and i are
following oracles given to us by
a skeletal gentleman if you wish to find
the person who killed your daughter
you should cooperate i imagine that not
even the clark scientist again he seems
to
federal power young but whatever enough
of your [ __ ]
oh why's everyone in their mother been
pissing in my ear today huh
never heard that before [ __ ] does this
mean you're ready to cooperate
may i enter the building york does have
dsl you're right
do whatever you want okay cool let's do
it if you think you can mess with the
clarkson's you got another thing coming
nice yes anime [ __ ] look at you
[ __ ]
they must be in the midst of their own
college people get put in their lips i
don't remember but it's like very just
require more work than we think
he's very pouty
also we have a freckle on our face in
the same spot and i have one like
here yet he's acting like he's a
full-blooded clarkson otherwise they
just have this giant pimple but still
um that was the most unexpected aspect
of our encounter
was it all he's only the son-in-law if
york do you remember when you walk up to
that man and you said you're not gonna
find the other world
to him because i [ __ ] do you
psychopath okay
okay let's do it let's go
good night angel
is it is a good tip drink water it is a
good tip
you gotta stay hydrated everybody stay
you know stay on it
all right i think we're gonna find some
combat ladies and gentlemen aside from
those weird [ __ ] dudes
do i need any more sure
oh which one is which one is
no we want the bullets
is this my inventory which is
what does withdrawal mean
i think this is right so we want to
let's do that
i do that do that
but like this seems right
but i really don't know okay sure
i can find out i guess all right
um let's do this great i can't wait
this is it zack a deadly premonition oh
[ __ ] that's the name of the video game
you know for some reason i'm getting
butterflies me too how about you
yeah it's time we went and saw this
other world for ourselves
video game is finally happening
i never thought we'd get this far
cool
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
yeah i probably am five hours into the
game conan and we're finally hitting
actual real combat which is fine
that's where he apparently doesn't like
it that much zach the countryside
is always so entertaining it has far
more stimuli to offer than the big city
thank you duffidus
this music is not even a little bit
fitting but this does look a lot like
those movies from the 80s were all
predicting the future life's simpler
than what philosophers make it out to be
in the end
you know i didn't expect it so
for the record i'm very easily scared of
video games it's a problem
um but survival horrors still manage to
be my favorite but people do say a lot
when i'm streaming
that they're more scared of my reactions
than they are at the game that's one of
you spawning
hey you stupid [ __ ]
i'm just going this way bye that music's
awesome from the first game
it sounds like he's saying [ __ ]
when he spawns in it really sounds like
that's what he's saying
there's another one where are you
i'm gonna need y'all to chill out all
right
i'm just need everyone to [ __ ] chill
out
i don't know what you want with me or
who you are or why you exist in the
cannon
i need you to [ __ ] chill out
okay i think there's one right here or
did he
it looks so bad how is it still getting
me i thought i'd be fine
but i'm not all right [ __ ]
oh okay
what is the objective even though
also genuinely who thought this music
was a good idea
ah another one of these yes my favorite
a caught puzzle
all right no no no no no that's not keep
going
i'm just going to let it go here we're
just going to let it go we're going to
keep moving [ __ ] you dude
oh [ __ ] he's reloading
bye all right cool peace
well this didn't sneak up on me when
they spawn in you know and it's smooth
i'm all right
what the [ __ ] am i doing
[ __ ] they are
very easy to kill but why do they look
like this
ah ah dude they are creepy
so there's that too you know they are
creepy
it's not you know not having an effect
on me
i hate you [ __ ] nope
stop it get away from me
i love it when i get to jump on them oh
you can headshot them i only just now
realize that
great no you don't
the well it does the same damage no
matter how far away you are so that's
good
why did i get stuck there um the aiming
is awful
okay is this it i just do this and then
leave
i mean there wasn't anything in any of
those
rooms and i would like to get away from
the scissor boys so let's go look peace
out
is it not like 3am in los angeles jacket
is 1am
in los angeles and also my dude
it's a friday night i do actually have
to work tomorrow but uh
this is what i would be doing on my
friday night anyway
is playing deadly premonition and
you when i'm like locked in my apartment
i sense because of
isolation why not stream it and talk to
people you know
i'd be doing it anyway where's the time
to do it
all right
why is this happened
a deadly premonition elise was murdered
in the video game
this is the second one i hope he says
something as a blessing in disguise
thank you
let's take a closer look and find out
exactly what went on
yeah this is a lot like the first game
but a lot worse
they've really downgraded um okay cool
oh no those are just safe mechanics
sh displays got axed zach lisa's limbs
were severed while she was still alive
she was kind of hot though will you see
some underboob
oh i take it back what's going on with
your thighs
are you all horse those are much too
out a frog maybe or your legs broken and
i'm being harsh
something's off smile
she must not have been able to feel any
pain san rouge isn't that powerful of a
drug
at least it shouldn't i don't like it
and look zach
another dragonfly the tattoo is just to
the side of her navel
she always carried the mark of a
clarkson yeah they're like brandon more
i want more she's saying that about
being axed
[ __ ] okay sweetie
she was highest
galena killed him is that what you're
implying zack the murder weapon was an
axe
how are you seeing this francis york
morgan i don't understand what gave him
the ability
lisa must have been dismembered while
she was still alive
and the woman holding the axe flashy
clothes
beautiful faces and that this must be
lisa's mother goddamn
look zach she's crying it's the polar
opposite of lisa's
so i feel like galena's being forced to
do it
galena is brandishing an axe while tears
stream down her face
she's killing her own daughter what's
going on in her head you know that's
a bit [ __ ] wow
it's amazing i can feel it
honey no you're being red powdered one
limb from lip
all right that's whatever drug she was
on
this must be san rouge but for some
reason
it looks more vibrant than all the
specimens it is not
rouge it is something else red seeds
okay zach is this a tall woman here
very stylish she'd stick out like a sore
thumb in this town rude but all right
is she watching the murder yes no oh
sorry she's clearly more than enough
spectator she must be deeply entwined
with this case
well you can be entwined and still be
watching something
okay elise
you're so beautiful this is [ __ ] up
this just [ __ ] up
she chopped her own daughter at me and
then they [ __ ]
dolly oh god that's the dolly she was
referring to other they [ __ ] froze
her
in their own warehouse this is [ __ ] up
let's see at least he lost dark from you
oh
ritual now you're
never done oh sick you'd be eternal uh
take it back they gave her a mortality
it's totally worth it
just wait for me i'll be with you soon
i'll always i mean this is the kind of
like same like kind of cult [ __ ] that
happened in the first game
it's true it's true
okay we did it
it's a [ __ ] good animation man lisa
clarkson was murdered here correct
after she died she was carried to the
spot underneath that bridge
what's with the foot on the ground you
guys see that
that seems like an accident i don't feel
like they meant to put that foot down
there can we pan back around so i could
take another look at that foot maybe
it i think is supposed to be on the top
but is accidentally glitched through the
ground to the bottom
you see it there it is i got a feeling
you didn't mean to do that
i think that that might be an accident
feature not a bug
why did the killer need to move her
um i mean pretty
standard i think i don't think that's
that uncommon but because it was a
ritual you dummy
bodies are usually only moved to cover
up evidence but this is different
lisa's body was enshrined
she was being shown off to someone
that's [ __ ] up tall woman
the ritual the altar a mother killing
her child
tell me a conclusion a monstrous giant
and a mysterious stylist i like to think
people talk about me that way
the whole sentence by the way a
monstrous giant and a mysterious stylish
woman
i like to think that like i can embody
both of those things
um you know i'm only 5 foot 10 which is
pretty tall
for a woman but i don't know if
you know it's i just that's what i want
to put in my
tender bio you imagine having a dating
app and putting that in your bio
and finding the one other person who has
any [ __ ] idea what that reference is
i'd marry them on the spot there's a
real
demon out there and it's got its sights
set on the
clocksons also seem like pieces of [ __ ]
so maybe you know they're the real demon
out there
they're like but zach big capitalism
awesome
in case we fbi agents are here to solve
isn't that right
[Laughter]
i'm laughing because uh malcolm
bracklini from twitch said i wouldn't
say you're monstrous
like it's such a funny thing to say that
casually
um but also how dare you
that's what i'm going for
we did it okay let's roll
solving crimes solving crimes
does whatever francis york morgan does
really [ __ ] up syllables there
oh i'm definitely taller than most women
it's not uh
not offended by it i'm cool with it
it's not uh not an issue okay
back to [ __ ]
chucklefox out here i guess no you don't
[ __ ]
oh
i didn't like that i didn't like it at
all how do i leave
oh well it's a video game so
i'm going to do that um
[ __ ]
all right okay
before i could even speak
i would like to leave
okay great sounds like he called me a
[ __ ] again
super rude i know i'm australian but
i'll give you a free pause
what does the exclamation point mean
like what are you trying to oh what
information are you trying to give me
what information do you think you're
giving me when you put that red
exclamation point up there
because i don't know
again they really should have chosen a
different song this doesn't work at all
okay we're gonna do that
bye oh i am literally just walking
backwards from where i came oh maybe not
no that didn't go that way that time
uh hi
no you don't
it's pretty satisfying i thought you
were gonna spawn
but no that that
indeed my [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh i gotta stop making fun of them
because sometimes they really do get me
you know
sometimes it's it's not all the time
but it does happen did i just [ __ ]
walk around a circle for a [ __ ]
reason
[ __ ] [ __ ] no you don't
are you no i don't have time
i got [ __ ] to be doing i can break these
though
oh cream at least i'm probably
getting stuff to make my cool charms
hopefully all right we're gonna go
move this thing again don't put your gun
away why have you done that
i don't don't support that
oh i keep forgetting that i can oh no
there's just a regulation
maybe am i using the other gun now is
that what you're telling me to do
i was uh trying to get through this way
oh i can't you just walk
okay let's keep moving
oh yeah it's this it is this one again
which i don't like because it takes a
lot longer don't feel good about it i
think there's going to be
i think there's going to be a boss fight
i would prefer to get back to patricia
or whatever no
goodbye no you don't nope i left
so sucks to be you guys
[ __ ] off dude
what are they trying to cut off is
is mans uncircumcised is this like some
kind of religious reference is that
what's happening
you shouldn't be allowed to do that it's
not fair
what do you want to cut off okay bro
okay everybody's gonna chill out
everybody's gonna chill out and leave me
alone okay you're gonna get off my dick
all right okay you'll all get your turn
you just need to pipe down
that door's locked which means more i'm
gonna spawn this is this
you know it's not terribly enjoyable
wait what i just had my regular gun back
oh i guess i must have picked up ammo
okay well this is happening still
somehow excuse me i will take thing
and then we will leave [ __ ]
it's still going
it's the chat just let me out
can i get on out of here
oh
okay i didn't expect this
this is gonna be the boss fight yeah
yeah official
this is embossed by [ __ ] if ever i've
seen it
cool i guess
your hand loses charge oh is that what's
happening my hands losing charge and
then they're replacing with the gun i'd
prefer to use the gun
it is a lost of a flashlight you're
right it's the little pocket thing they
have
yeah okay i don't want that for
us you gonna make me fight a giant baby
this is [ __ ] japanese as hell
same dude same dude i really
did it i finally completed the first
ritual now the plan
will begin and the red ones plan
will begin what the [ __ ] is that
zach this case is going to be allowed i
certainly didn't expect to run into a
monster like that
honestly i'm not one for violence but
i'm not just going to stand here and die
what do you think should we read off it
right
now it's the red one's turn
it sucks that they killed off the only
hot chick soon
and in the end we'll be together
okay do you talk about lease
[Music]
red seats huh i'm familiar with those
please well there's your confession i
guess they really
did justice we figured that out a lot
faster than i expected us to
so pure adorable
and beautiful we did
you son of a [ __ ] what did you do to
mine
you literally chopped her up in pieces
um
again really feel like we think okay
okay
what's gonna happen here then
oh well this should actually be kind of
okay
this might actually be fine
the first game has bits that are quite
hard um
i think it also had difficulty settings
it was just a lot more of a video game
all right i'm gonna need y'all the
[ __ ] pipe down out here no
i don't i just you know i don't want any
of this
um whereas i feel like this one is very
easy in comparison
but i know that sweary doesn't care
about video game [ __ ] so
so that could be why
oh yep yep a lot of cut cut snip snips
off
what are that happening out here
you're really pissing me off you're
going to have like three phases so
comfortable now holy red seeds protect
me she has the
this is related it's related to the
first game what are you
no it can't be you came here to stop out
yeah for sure [ __ ] i for sure did
don't yeah how much we sacrificed
how many tears of blood we cried
okay for the red one's plan i didn't ask
you a life story though
so go off i guess the red one gave me
the honor of lighting the flame
i'm not just spinning i maybe need to
chill out
okay yeah
what the [ __ ] okay
great actually she looks dope
i'm actually like vibing hard
with what you're wearing
[Music]
girl nah that's a glow up if ever i've
seen one look at that on the boob
you look beautiful kalina
is this your truth gosh hollywood would
have been all over you
i agree although you probably would have
been typecast as a gross monster
the kind that heroes always we
are going to make a new world
okay
okay all right then
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] up i guess
oh that's rude okay yeah i hear you
oh ugh
do you want me to shoot a rom off is
that like what the suggestion is
i should wish i could run
oh i have to shoot my hand
all right it's fine it's manageable we
can do it i think
but oh it seems like it's so close every
time
gotta be like a palm that you want me to
shoot specifically
why did you recoil like i did that to
your face
yeah that's what i thought
she sounds like she's vomiting okay
that's more concerning
ah oh what
what in the [ __ ] what is devil daggers
is a really good game you guys should
play um
i recommend it like super highly
i prefer not to um but yeah i recognize
that was a reference for like two people
maybe
because i don't know that devil daggers
was terribly popular
okay all right they are
doing damage to me but i don't ah
[Music]
i don't feel very concerned about it
wait wait am i not doing damage to her
what is happening all right
okay fit rude
am i seriously not no okay just
picky no this might be happening
i did not say deviled eggs i did say
double daggers
all right well yeah yeah yeah i know i
know
it's all very funny ah oh that one
yeah they got me there they did get me
there
come on
disaster aversion bonus we did it that
was very easy
um
it's fine honey it's still hot
i mean i'd still touch it
like you need to chill out a bit but
excellent all right
okay yeah no me too me too me too
i feel like the bowling mini game was
harder than the boss fight
um which is why this game is a 10 out of
10. the real boss fight was the bowling
that was just like some side [ __ ] you
know that was like a
you know so it's like a monster hunter
like well i guess you could go fight her
if you want like a cool new
weapon or whatever which is the hand
thing
but the bowling that strike it's the
real boss fight
all right what's this
oh i didn't expect that actually
um i don't know what i have expected
this whole time but i didn't expect that
my sweet little
galena clarkson you are now under arrest
on suspicion of the murder of lisa
clarkson
and the illegal disposal of her court
you have the right to remain silent
tool is awesome it's only like 1am it's
not too bad i'll go to bed soon though
anything you say may be used against you
in a court of law
that's enough zach do you legally have
to say the whole thing though dude
don't be [ __ ] yourself over like that
zach
pardon my language but this case can go
fast
does she have a flipper foot no she's
wearing heels
and uh here we go is a loading stream
you know
take 20 minutes oh that one was actually
pretty
pretty speedy is she in prison now
i owe you one mistake you carry over the
hallway like that sorry you had to get
all caught up in our town's dirt no dude
happy too
i didn't expect you to catch the
criminal this soon though
you never fail to impress me anytime
melvin
i love you come on clg
let's head back to the office mr york
and i both got a lot of cleanup work to
take care of
so i don't know why this happened now i
just gotta figure out what i'm gonna
tell the clarkson's well i think they're
probably not the biggest problem
some [ __ ] just really went down this
investigation has only just begun yes
what but we got the killer this case is
much more complicated than it seems yes
agreed you mean you're going to keep
searching the tank yeah where's the
stylish lady
of course i'm going to find out at the
moment i'm
after a tall stylish woman does that
ring any bells
stylish you lost me
what's that got to do with anything so
much melvin so much you're so innocent
zach and i saw her with her own eyes we
need to find her i'm positive
you're probably talking about professor
r cool professor r
from the jazz bar he rhymed very nice
very nice yeah
i mean she's the only person in town you
could call stylish
she's tall too great but
what is it melvin uh
well well out with it i love him
don't let your 10 year old daughter
upstage you here sheriff
you're looking for a stylish woman right
yes we've established that
then i think you're barking up the wrong
tree with professor r
she isn't exactly a normal woman
if you catch my drift i hear you loud
and clear
melvin you're careless in every sense of
the word but i believe you operate on
the side of good in most cases
with that in mind i'm disappointed to
see that you carry some pressure is your
trans character
uh what but is she the type to forbid
customers from entering her jazz bar
due to the color oh my god york look at
you go no
she ain't like that well then case
closed melvin i think we should call it
a day
i'm going to head back to my hotel and
get some sleep
that was unexpected report to send back
to the bureau patty
thank you very much why haven't they
done that investigation i'll be counting
on you again tomorrow okay
i just helped an fbi oh yeah you did
patty you're [ __ ] you're a saint
sort of [ __ ] but yeah you know
almost a teenager we'll work on it
figure it out melvin one more thing
you needn't worry about what to tell the
clarkson's i'm sure they already know
that galena's been arrested so you're
just not gonna
say anything to him after all this is
lucario it's true
it's a good point york is a genius
sweet all right we done did it uh game's
over you guys we finished the game but
really
i'm gonna go to sleep uh thank you all
for joining me
um while playing this absolutely
ridiculous video game
um i think i will continue to just do
more
you know so
that'd be cool hopefully tomorrow um i
am streaming for roosty teeth at some
point tomorrow during the day but
yeah i'll share it if i'm gonna stream
again so
that's pretty much it um have a good
night oh good day everyone
and i will see you guys next time bye
you